that's mephisto
it's mephisto who is it if they don't
show it i'm going to be so upset
who is it oh it's boss said it wasn't
going to be everybody
you said evan peters wasn't going to be
in it
she recast pietro okay so that's how
they did it
that's how they did it welcome back to
new rockstars did
one division just at viv quicksilver i
mean either we just got our first
official x-men crossover in the mcu or
more likely this quicksilver is
not quicksilver wtf or
wanda
this is inside marvel it's our one
division after show we're talking about
episode five i'm eric boss here with
jessica clements hi
hello hi hello
hello trying to harmonize like that
intro
stop it okay let's get into it this is
insane we're gonna explain
all your big questions that you had from
this episode starting with
why evan peters from the fox x-men
movies not
aaron terry johnson from the mcu is
playing wanda's brother quicksilver
on wandavision and there are a lot of
other things that we're going to talk
about this episode
tomorrow will be my in-depth shot by
shot breakdown of all the easter eggs
you missed in this episode coming up on
youtube
so uh i gotta re-watch it like five
times to find all this stuff
it's a labor love oh and by the way i am
wearing our new latest obsession
shirt an unusual couple it's awesome
it's got secret augmented reality easter
eggs in it
you can get it at newrockstarsmerch.com
and if you get this shirt you'll get the
opportunity
to write in a custom shout out that will
appear at the bottom of the screen in
these inside marvel episodes some of the
people who
uh supported us let's see we got very
gonzales who says i want to give a shout
out to my fiance
austin drapeau or dr paul this
is part of valentine's day gift he is a
big fan oh
we love it when uh couples uh come
together
as a result of marvel content and uh we
just love seeing the love happen
because in the mcu the love is
not happening we just love love we love
love uh also let's see tanya
stargel says mephisto is ralph it has to
be uh yeah we'll be talking about that i
think uh
we'll see we'll see where that theory's
going david s anderson says
what about all the stuff that sword was
doing is it possible they
maybe experimented on vision before
wanda got him yeah yeah that's gonna be
one of the things we talked about later
this episode
as well because yeah that's a big huh
and
uh yeah we are simulcasting this live on
stereo you can get this app for free and
follow us at stereo.com
new rockstars and if you're listening to
us on stereo right now it looks like we
have over a thousand of you listening
this is the first time we've broken the
thousands because this episode is so
insane and every scene every cut from
the camera is important
and i was getting and it's the longest
episode it's 42 minutes
the other ones are around like 30. give
me an hour and a half
the long episode i want lord of the
rings extended cut
all deleted scenes included i i want a
four hour cut of one
i want a director's cut too i want
everything and uh if you are listening
on stereo right now
we are going to be doing a special
exclusive bonus segment at the end of
the show where we're going to be
reacting in real time
to the voicemails that you send us and
if you missed the live broadcast
you can catch us next week at 8am
pacific stereo.com
new rockstars that's how you get it it's
free hey jessica tell us what happened
this episode
we have so much to talk about i can't
wait so we're now in the 80s if you guys
haven't noticed
if you haven't noticed we're in the 80s
we opened to see wanda envision trying
to get tommy and billy to go to sleep
they won't go to sleep because they're
infants
and then of course agnes intrudes and is
like i can help
uh wanda's like yes please while
vision's like no
maybe not and this is when we see agnes
like get taken out of the
the series jimmy take that again we get
those acting like
words we get those thespian words that i
don't know
but once that happens that's when vision
is starting to recognize that there's
something going wrong here wanda's just
trying to like overlook it but
visions like wanda is noticing something
that she's not telling me we see monica
going under some tests she's explaining
what uh happened to her when she was in
the bubble explaining that she was like
feeling like she was drowning and that
she had a lot of pain and it was all
grief which is
we will get into in a second um at the
briefing later on with tyler hey where
tyler basically says that wanda's a
terrorist and that she's doing
all of this and it's bad and that we
should destroy her well monica is saying
that she's not a terrorist
none of these is premeditated like
aggression
and that's when we get footage from
sword headquarters uh that
hayward somehow just got he's been
sitting on this
he's the acting director and he just got
footage
of wanda breaking into that he said
something like
he just got permission to share it but
like he's acting director
who's he gotta check in yeah who's the
yeah who's the permission
but you there's a board of shareholders
at sword like let's not
release it the stock price will dive
no oh yeah the stocks the stocks right
and the stock
sucks and so he releases the footage
which shows wanda breaking into sword
no one in the footage is freaking out
until she gets into the lab
and then she like destroys the glass the
scientists like shudder and we see
vision
taken apart obviously being dissected
and worked on and for some reason
hayward took that as an act of
aggression when i'm like what were you
doing to him
which we will get into we go back inside
one division the family now has a puppy
the boys turn from infants to five years
old to 10 year olds
and want to begin showing people her
powers and she doesn't care anymore
which strikes vision with this is
ridiculous you promised we wouldn't do
this
and wanda's like we shouldn't have to
hide ourselves anymore
what is going on with her she's going
through tears of like vision's now
starting to recognize something is truly
happening
back at sword monica darcy and we were
trying to find ways to safely render
west view that's when we realized
monica's outfit was made of the material
she entered the bubble in which was her
kevlar vest
kevlar pants man get me a pair of those
no one's getting shot in the crotch
today
they realize that wanda's just
re-rewriting that's what she says
rewriting the material that goes in
there
it's still the same material it's
absolutely real it comes back out the
way when it or the way
like she changed it inside yeah jessica
can i just ask
can people in the mcu stop just picking
up guns and firing them indoors without
warning
peggy carter did the same in the first
cat movie just tell people in the room
with like hey i'm gonna do a quick test
here if you want to put on some uh
and it's also like just tell us what
you're doing like you could be like
i think this is made out of my kevlar
and they're just like
shoot rather than just words steal his
gun
yeah words before shooting so warning
before shooting i think that's fine
so they realize it's made out of kavalar
which is great so they're like what if
we send something in there of that time
period maybe she won't change it
so they send in an 80s ass drone a big
ass
80s drone and they're just going to go
in there but hayward
of course puts missiles on the drone
that monica doesn't know about and
shoots at wanda
which is like 101 if you're an acting
director that's truly up to nothing
why would you entice it why would you
harm what's starting the art it's
i and why didn't you tell monica again
these sword agents
they have a shoot first policy we're not
gonna tell my partners or the people i
work with that i have
live ammo about the fire just talk about
it
on twitter i was like he is either the
bad guy or severely awful at his job
because there was like when he did that
i was like why would you think that's a
good idea
she took like 150 people hostage you
think a
missile's gonna stop her off an 80s
drone
either way wanda takes that [ __ ]
seriously and she breaks through the
barrier and
throws the drone at them and tells them
straight up don't come back into my home
this is my like this is where i feel
safe do not come back this is your one
warning
and then makes all the gunmen turn their
guns on hayward so it shows that like
i'm this powerful
why would you want to mess with me which
is true
don't know why hayward this is why he's
just stupid either way
on the vision ends of things he's
working back at his computer companies
hanging out with norm
he's setting up the computers and
internet and that's when they get an
email
from sword about darcy's information and
everyone starts reciting the email
around vision like a
like a scary horror cult and vision is
like there's something weird
takes norm's mind suppresses it and
brings the normal norm who uh
i forget his name back to reality and
he's freaking out because his dad is
sick
he's in a bunch of pain he doesn't know
where he is he's freaking out yeah so
jessica do you think that was a
continuity error with last episode how
we saw that vision awakening
written on the notes do you think they
just like shot that out of sync and they
thought that the 80s episode was gonna
come before
episode four what oh okay oh that
is this is the brain
hey okay so back to the theory uh back
to my everything no okay so
i didn't even think about that i didn't
even think about that and time is so
crazy here because time and wanda vision
is a lot quicker than time outside it
could be like an hour and it's like a
day there
what if this doesn't make sense maybe
but what if that time when
vision awoke him was so long ago in one
division but we
just got the information and sword does
that make sense is that
possible there's obviously some time
dilation going on i just don't
think based off of um geraldine slash
monica getting ejected at the end of the
70s episode the 80s episode didn't
happen until
after she was ejected and that's where
the whole
norm awakening thing did for darcy to
make those notes i have a feeling that
the
the id board was not assembled
originally
in the outline of the sequence of events
until
later earlier to this episode to give
audiences some desperately needed
context because they were worried the
general viewers might have been like i
don't know what's going on give me
something please
harm isn't real and we knew this going
into it but we didn't really think about
it until wanda
disturbed it yeah so they find a dog
earlier in the episode they name it
sparky because he electrocutes himself
but it's a no it's a
ode to the vision comic books the dog
sparky and
the twins find the dog dead
and wanda has to explain to the twins
about death
and they're like mom you can bring back
people from the dead and she's like no i
can't why would you say that
like life shouldn't be i don't see agnes
how thirsty agnes got in that second
she's like well
what you can i thought it was more out
of fear i thought agnes was like
okay wait what the hell you can bring
people back to life who
are you yeah yeah we got to talk about
agnes too
that's interesting sorry i don't mean to
interrupt i keep interrupting no we keep
talking we're going back and forth you
are a jerk but we are just talking
i hate you but let me fit it i love you
so the twins are like now figuring out
about death they're figuring out their
mom can do a lot of stuff but the kids
also have too much insight
there's too many times the kids are just
like asking questions and i'm like okay
something's up with these little weirdos
uh so
back home wanda's cleaning up vision
tells her about norm
a fight ensues immediately and they're
interrupted by a knock at the door
and this knock is so suspenseful because
visions like you did this and she's like
i didn't make the knock happen
and we see that white hair and i go it's
pietro
it's pietro and then i'm like you get
off the covey and roll there yeah
please no one come for me online and
then i
and then we see that it's evan peters
and on twitter
i went i was like of course it's obvious
but when i say it's obvious i meant
of course they did it this way why don't
i think about this it's a television
program
like it's one division like of course
they could they could recast anything
they could do whatever they want because
it's a tv show and a tv show and they
did it
a couple things uh you doing the little
piece of thing did you notice how
elizabeth olsen's uh
accent started to come back a little bit
when she's talking there you are
that's when i was like oh yeah i forget
she has an accent that's what i like
immediately was like oh yeah
i did love how like the credits were
rolling over their argument like she was
just trying to like cut to commercial or
cut to the end of the other thing
i wanted a vision to like pick up one of
those yellow credits and just hit her
with it and then she picks up one and
they start like jousting with like
like in too many cooks how like the
titles become alive i was hoping that
sometimes that'd be fun this show
is getting more and more scary like it's
yes so really it's so horrifying
well to you and me jessica we knew this
was a horror from the very beginning we
were we've been frightened since
you know minute one i'm eating it up it
is a
full-on three entree from panda express
i'm going in
half chow mein half fried rice i am in
it
like it's so scary we have a couple
questions from our stereo listeners that
we're gonna take as we uh
dive into the big uh wtf this episode
so just right off the bat let's talk
about the elephant in the room
pedro are they retconning him is like
did the old pedro never exist i'm like
this is the pedro that was technically
there now i think that's how it works or
yeah yeah yeah
who do you guys think sent pietro to
wanda
if wanda is the one who didn't call for
him
oh okay yeah what is our a big question
how are we going to encapsulate all this
jessica
wonder oh i don't want to recast pietro
and also is this our big cameo i guess
that everyone's talking about
i think it is the big cameo i think this
is i think it is
okay so let's remind everyone evan
peters played quicksilver in the fox
x-men movie so uh the first one was days
of future past in 2014 and then x-men
apocalypse 2016
dark phoenix came out 2019 and then he
did do a cameo in deadpool 2. that was
awesome
uh so he's been in those movies the
pietro maximoff of the mcu
of this marvel cinematic universe is uh
wanda's brother played by aaron taylor
johnson we saw him in age of ultron
and he was god didn't see that's coming
dead
um now the fox x-men movies did not
include scarlet witch but they were
pretty clear that magneto eric lyncher
was his father was quicksilver's father
and the mcu they really avoided
mentioning mutants
uh at all in age of ultron because at
the time fox had uh the rights to those
characters
uh and in this episode it's interesting
you may have heard juan and pietro's
parents were listed as irina and oleg
maximoff different names
different names from even the foster
parents in the comics um than than this
so
we'll see if that's gonna be connected
but the crossover is confirmed by this
episode's own
audio description if you play it on
disney plus you hear a voice kind of
describing what they see and people from
the show had to kind of like approve all
that stuff
and the voice says the version from the
x-men films
of pietro so they want us to make that
connection this isn't just a
coincidental this isn't just cassidy
being like oh that doesn't matter
that is an intentional connection they
want us to care about
therefore jessica i think we can say it
what we're seeing is the first official
x-men crossover in the mcu
i think so i think so completely i think
this is and i like that it's quick so
well
i kind of had to be well first we're
talking x-men not mutants because it's
like
i think the fantastic four guys come
with this there have been mutants you
could say wanda max muff is a mutant
uh yeah yeah yeah yeah just they have so
this is the x-men coming in
and also i think it's good to note that
like they
reiterated so much in this episode that
whatever comes out of that world stays
the same
so there could be i don't know where the
math is but wanda if she is bringing
people back to the life
pietro could come out of that bubble
with her absolutely now um
we can't say this is for sure yet an
x-men thing because we don't know what
this cameo means
but it does potentially open all kinds
of doors now the first thing we should
say is that wanda herself did not recast
pietro
as darcy thought you know that doorbell
rang
but i think wanda seemed very sincere
about not causing it she admitted to
causing other things but this was
something that she was completely caught
off guard by
so peter's pietro evan peters pietro is
the doing of
whatever force is really pulling the
strings in west view
i think just by process of elimination
there um now on one level
i think we can all see this as a clear
meta joke by marvel studios right
this is kind of like you know jessica
you're saying this is what sitcoms do
they recast actors pretend nothing
happened
you know aunt viv that's what happens
it's it's messed up
but they do it uh the mcu even did this
with hulk and with rhodey
in the early phase one films and the way
evan peters
is acting seems to be like acknowledging
that whole sitcom history he's
he's playing it up he's like the fonz
he's like who's the boss tony danza he's
like uncle jesse
cool uncle who shows up out of nowhere
you know hey
what's going on here give me a squeezer
give me a kiss what's going on i loved
when he entered with that voice i was
like what is going on
what a strong choice
now this episode confirmed that wanda is
rewriting reality but she needs solid
matter to do it with
unless it's coming from her envision so
she
did indeed steal vision's remains from
sword hq
whoa we that was confirmed we saw that
um
but is she then using aaron taylor
johnson corpse pietro
and rewriting him to look like evan
peters no i don't think
so um we could see this as evidence of
the marvel
multiverse finally happening now that
disney owns all of the fox film
properties marvel studios is retconning
all
the fox x-men movies as just kind of an
alternate reality
within the broader mcu multiverse uh
rumor has that we could be seeing a very
similar thing with the next spider-man
film bringing in characters from
sony spider-verses that used to be in
separate universes like doc
ock and jimmy fox electro and now
wanda's westview anomaly could be just
like
warping into these alternate realities
in order to
pull in those outside elements and just
make them part of a world
and if that is what we're looking at
that sets the stage for
all kinds of x-men crossovers in the mcu
like
there are rumors that the big cameo that
paul bettany and elizabeth olsen have
been talking about
could be ian mckellen magneto patrick
stewart charles xavier
if this ends up being a more direct
house of m adaptation it would be pretty
nuts to see mckellen as magnus
the ruler of an alternate mutant
dominates society
um i don't think yet
this is the big cameo jess i i i think
it's too early in the season it's
episode five we have four more episodes
and i just no disrespect to evan peters
paul bettany described this
as like some thespian some legend of
stage and screen that he had always
wanted to work with
is that evan peters i guess it could be
sir ian mckellen or anyone there's a lot
of options i just don't know if evan
peters is the guy
yeah i get i think it's because in the
back of my head when i was like yeah
evan peter's gonna be in it and you were
like allegedly
and i was like okay so he might not be
in it and so i landed i thought
so hard that like he's not he might not
be in it we're just like
he just wasn't confirmed you know and we
couldn't uh marvel would never
uh say it what if paul benny is like
this is my strong thespian
uh i see where you're coming from
because paul bettany and elizabeth olsen
are phenomenal actors that i feel like
they'd be like yeah we're on the same
plane with evan peters
and right now i think quicksilver is
kind of breaking the internet but not to
the extent of mark hamill's cameo
in the mandalorian final episode like
people are watching this being like
wait wasn't that guy in the other movies
and then they're coming here to new rock
stars we're kind of trying to figure it
out with you guys but
like it's this is not when you see mark
hamill's face
and uh he's rescuing baby yoda everyone
knows what that means everyone knows
immediately so
it would need to be someone who's
immediately recognizable to everyone
that's
true well the only person it could be is
magneto
that's why i'm thinking or just an actor
an actor if it's like someone like
freaking you know
jim carrey or daniel t lewis or somewhat
insane
like people were like what is he doing
in the show that would break the
internet you know
george clooney just shows up yeah
clooney clooney
there is some kind of mutant connection
going on here uh vision was reading
charles darwin's the descent of man
which i think that could have been not
to human evolution right mutants are
replacing man that's kind of the classic
debate there the other alternative
peter's pietro
could maybe just be a trick that's being
played on wanda
a deceit marvel studios is just using
evan peters as maybe the promise of a
future multiverse
explosion in upcoming titles but it's
not happening yet
uh because again these quicksilver's
words
classically wanda didn't see that one
coming you know
evan peters pietro rang that doorbell
wanda did not
call him there he came on some other
orders um so using that
assumption this pietro could be a kind
of mask or a puppet a shape-shifted form
of whatever darker entity is doing this
to wanda maybe just trying to keep her
calm
by using her resurrected brother now
that resurrected vision isn't really
doing the trick they're fighting so now
they bring in the brother to try to keep
her taint well that's the
that's the thing that's why i think she
did bring pietro in there
because everyone's been acknowledging
like i'm in so much
pain and then one when monica was like
it's all grief
it's obvious that they're feeling the
pain that wanda is feeling
and so when she was like i didn't do
that i think those are like the pieces
that we're getting that she's
unconsciously doing
yeah i think she's like i want my the
man of my love the love of my life is
fighting with me he doesn't want to stay
in this home that i made for him i'm
trying to protect him he doesn't know
that he's dead on the outside of this
bubble
who is the next person that can comfort
me and that's when pietro comes to the
door
if it is just wanda's subconscious
that's creating these things
that kind of takes away this whole
seeming misdirect of hayward being so
gung-ho on her being the villain that
feels like classic storytelling setup
of make this make the audience feel like
this person's villain feel like we're
only in episode five right now we have
four more episodes in order to subvert
expectations and we know agnes is
cooking up something on the side
you know so i feel like there's some
other malevolent entity
that is at work here i get it but it's
also just like
that emotion is so raw and sad
that it's like yeah i guess it's like
hey words like see she is the villain
but it's like no
she's heartbroken and you guys were
dissecting
the love of her life and also we don't
talk about how the hell does she figure
out that he was at sword headquarters
that might have something to do with why
she looked at hayward the way she did
when she was like
again and like stared directly at him
yeah she must erect
every other uh government building
before she got the sword looking for her
and the videos when she's ripping the
doors apart
everyone around and the other videos are
just walking normally so i was like why
is everybody acting cool about wanderers
walking through this place but i think
emotionally she's just so wrecked that
it makes sense why she'd go
this person has the powers to like
destroy thanos
and she's heartbroken and dealing
emotionally mentally with everything i
think
all this is true jessica i think this is
very much part of uh
wanda's character development is like in
order to get to the point where she is
kind of this like
antagonistic figure but she's not doing
it alone like
why are they setting up all these other
things on the side then if it were just
a story
about a uh an avenger who's having a
meltdown a psionic meltdown
a true house of m thing and if it was
just house of m
why are you bringing up these other
mysterious things why aren't you just
giving us answers on those things way
earlier and this is why i'm like hayward
is definitely
a part of the problem he definitely is
doing something
he is part he's enticing a lot of it
even if he's like
if his motives he thinks are like it's
not it's not the same as killmonger not
the same as killmonger but i'm saying
he probably thinks he's doing right his
intentions are probably like
i need to do what's right for the world
but it's like you're trying to create an
enemy out of wanda maximoff which worked
in watchmen
but i don't think it's going to work in
this in watchman 2006. not watching
the tv series and there is also
something unknown inside west view
there's like a couple things unknown
inside west
view there is uh it's not just like
wanda's subconscious
these are cognitive actors who are
making choices that are trying
to subvert her or trying to use her or
exploit her in some way
but jessica we have to address the fact
that this is air this is evan peters
this is a guy we've seen play
quicksilver before
so that is what people are confused
about why whoever is doing this why
are they using that face why are they
using evan peters this
tells us that whatever this entity is
whether it's wanted subconscious or
whether it's something else
they must have access to a kind of
multiverse
i'm thinking it might be that they
pulled they had to pull a quick silver
sleeve but they had to pull it from a
reality
where quicksilver was still alive and
this version of quicksilver in these fox
x-men movies has been one that has been
progressing through the decades like uh
uh days of future past was in the 70s
apocalypse was in the 80s uh and the
version of pietro we're seeing now is
kind of like that
sweet dreams version of quicksilver in
x-men apocalypse
and then he was only ever in the uh dark
phoenix movie
uh where i feel like he was a bit wasted
but that was in the early 90s
and a weird thing to point out none of
those actors age in those movies
uh what hank mccoy looks just like he
did in the 60s
during the cuban missile crisis and it's
the 90s now and he has an age today
being immune also comes with
being gorgeous and then within like
eight years he's gonna turn into uh
kelsey grammer no i guess there's maybe
timelines there it's a it's a strange
world the fox
x-men movies but i think there might be
something to that to that decade
progression maybe like in this alternate
reality
they just reached out and pulled someone
and because he kind of aged through the
decades at the same pace
he just kind of neatly fits like there's
a nice convergence point in the
realities that's fine and so they're
just like they reached out and the first
one to
to answer that call was just this
happened to me this evan peters
quicksilver so
where i'm gonna land for right now i
think there is some uh malevolent entity
that is at work
and that is say it with me everyone
methisto don't hate me don't hate me i
think
evan peters peter might be me with wanda
and why do i think that because i think
everything's mephisto won
but secondly there's a couple clues here
he does say he wants to squeeze his
stinking sister to
death you know like it's not just a hug
it's interesting choice of words it's
kind of like devil in the details there
let's just mark it down it might become
important later
i think you're being crazy hey let me
finish
when wanda asks pietro he does not
answer
he does not say yeah it's me all he does
he gives us kind of confused like huh
huh like he doesn't answer the question
it kind of reminds me of when
uh peter parker asked edith if mysterio
was dead
and she goes all illusions are down it's
like why not just answer the question
maybe now some people are saying you can
see a faint red glow
around uh quicksilver's hairline maybe
his jacket buttons when he first arrives
folks watch the whole episode that red
tinted glare is everywhere
it's everywhere it's everywhere
especially in the scene where they find
dead sparky it's like on their outlines
yeah they did something with a filter
in post-production to just like up the
reds i don't think they had red lights
on set doing all this it really is just
kind of in a spectrum glare
i think it's awesome that they did this
when visions at work it's
everywhere it's beaming out i also think
it's like we're gonna see more red as
the world starts to fall apart
because visions just recognizing that
it's not real
i want to know why she can't control him
but we can talk about that in a second
there is another creepy visual clue i
think in that moment that pietro walks
through the door i'm not really sure
it's there i might have just been seeing
things i'm gonna go more into that in
the breakdown if it is there i don't
want to sound like a full in case it's
there
okay okay just just in case just in case
watch the breakdown watch the breakdown
uh now we have to assume that um no one
new has entered westview
uh because sword has a perimeter set up
they're monitoring everything
so this version of pietro especially if
we assume wanda did not expect him
must have been in the town the whole
time
right he must have been one of those
they mentioned like thousands of people
right
he must have been one of them uh because
i think it's clear that the kids were
able to be manifested
originally but they came directly from
wanda herself
literally from her body um she didn't do
that with pietro so pietro must have
been one of these other dudes hanging
out in the shadows until this particular
moment
i we gotta point out this episode
definitely move the ball forward on
agnes right
uh vision doesn't trust her around the
kids there's that creepy moment where
the kids seemingly disappear it's like
she took the baby like the witch
in that robert eggers movie the witch
like the baby's gone you know um
there she says that line she's got a few
tricks up her sleeve
uh she stops to take uh wand is getting
more comfortable around her she might
have killed that dog by the way
i think it was wanda that killed that
dog of course
oh how dare you i would love one if
you're happy to point the fingers
i wanted to go on record that i am not
on that man's side he is
obviously crazy i'm sure you heard we
got another mention of ralph
agnes says that he sprays lavender or
squeezes lavender on her every night
her high high libido someone somewhere
said the lavenders used to repel dark
energy
i don't know about that i feel like
people use everything to repel dark
energy sage
would be probably the go-to there right
so i still think ralph could be our
missing person who i
labeled m in a video we did this week uh
i think he is agnes
partner whoever this is ralph is uh
tired of staying behind the scenes
and i think what happened is he said uh
he kind of pulled a thanos and said
fine i'll do it myself and he entered
wanda's home posing as her brother
but they casted evan peters to show that
there is something off about this pietro
if it were aaron taylor johnson we would
trust it too much they wanted a
pietro whose face they could melt away
into someone else
or reveal to be plain someone else evan
peters could be playing one of these
other
uh like dark horses yeah uh and we do
know from evan peter's work in american
horror story the guy can go dark he can
play devil's
rancher he's got rain he can be watch it
when we go to a new decade it's going to
be
ralph is going to be revealed and it's
going to be evan peters playing ralph
and it's just going to be we're going to
be like what is going on
ralph yeah so i just don't know jessica
i don't think this is on par with luke
skywalker and the mandalorian i might be
wrong this might be
maybe a very big deal to elizabeth olsen
to have evan peters quicksilver
uh cast in this series i think it is a
pretty big deal i just don't think it's
that big i think there's more could be
there's so much happening why add
another big thing unless it's magneto
because that would make sense story wise
but like
it's such unless unless unless which we
will get into
the engineer that monica is talking
about referring to
reed richards and it's someone playing a
bit we'll talk about it i don't want to
get too much into it i want to save it
yeah let's
before we get to these other questions
let's uh thank some people helped us
make this episode starting with our
friends
at shutter so shutter is the streaming
service with the best selection of
horror thriller and supernatural movies
series and originals from hollywood
favorites and cult classics to original
series and critically acclaimed new
genre films that you won't find anywhere
else
streaming uncut and commercial free
right to your favorite devices
stream the largest collection of human
curated horror and thriller content for
just 5.99 a month
right on your roku your xbox or apple tv
whatever else you
have so that you can watch some scary
content
i really love that they have so many
great foreign horror films like
go overseas they'll scare you in whole
new ways uh
like uh train to busan it's one of the
best zombie movies of all time
they have tons of other great korean
japanese and italian horror classics as
well
so get started streaming the best horror
thriller and supernatural content
shutter's expertly curated collection
includes must-see titles like
color out of space host the mortuary
collections
plus all the best horror documentaries
in the hit
creep show tv series from executive
producer greg nicotero of the walking
dead
try shutter free for 30 days go to
shutter.com and use the promo code
wandavision so they know that we sent
you that's s-h-u-d-d-e-r.com and promo
code wandavision
i have shutter and they have another
great movie called one cut of the dead
just as an fyi to anybody watching it
i have shutter i love love my horror
films they're good to go this episode
was also sponsored by
bluetooth guys you can increase your
performance and get that extra
confidence
in bed at bluechew.com that's blue like
the color blue and then
chew the thing that you do with your
teeth uh now blue chew
brings you the first chewable with the
same fda approved active ingredients as
viagra and cialis
you can take them any time day or night
even on a full stomach so that you can
be ready whenever the opportunity
arises blue chew is prescribed online by
licensed physicians so you don't have to
go to the doctor's office or wait in
line at the pharmacy
and it ships right to your door in a
discreet package and they're made in the
usa
and since bluetooth prepares and ships
direct they are cheaper than a pharmacy
you don't have to leave the house
right now we've got a special deal for
our listeners visit bluetooth.com and
get your first shipment for free
when you use our special promo code
wandavision just pay five dollars in
shipping
again that is bluee chew.com promo code
one of vision to try it free
bluetooth is a better cheaper choice and
we thank them for sponsoring this
podcast and remember when you support
our sponsors you help make this podcast
possible so be sure to use our promo
code onedivision
bluetooth.com and lastly we want to
thank our friends at stereo for
sponsoring us
if you have more questions or theories
that we're not getting to we probably
will get to them in our bonus q a
segment
only on stereo we see about 1100 of you
uh listening to us this is so amazing i
can't wait to hear what you guys have to
say about this
so uh right now jessica and i are live
on stereo as we record this
stereo is a great app with uh live
social conversations live it's kind of
like a podcast that you can interact
with
in real time new rockstars has three
weekly
new shows on this app including a this
live inside marvel taping that we do
every friday
and after we've wrapped on the youtube
show jessica and i are going to answer
your questions and hear your theories
but that's only on stereo and if you
missed it uh this week if you're
watching us on youtube just
join us every friday at eight a.m live
uh you can also join us every monday and
wednesday over on the stereo app for new
rockstars other shows including new
rockstars news with
me and philip molina on wednesdays and
then our editors show on mondays
uh download the stereo app and follow us
at stereo dot com slash new rockstars
click that link in the description and
again that's stereo dot com slash new
rockstars we're having a great time on
stereo follow new rockstars and get
notified
every time we go live all right jessica
we have
actually a couple of stereo questions
that we want to take do you guys
think that agnes straight up
killed sparky it was
really suspicious
she was holding his body i don't think
she straight up lawn ordered it but yeah
isn't it possible that the drone strike
that was sent in killed him and then she
had to find a way to explain why he was
dead to the twins
interesting yeah so let's talk about
what happened to sparky here
uh sparky uh supposedly died according
to
agnes by eating azaleas which are i
guess poisonous
to dogs like everything is poisonous to
dogs yeah i could eat azaleas and be
fine
sparky was like doomed from the start
little poor guy
like licked out an electrical socket and
that's how he got his name
there's a couple different versions of
this this is similar to what happens
in the uh to sparky in the comics he
eats a uh
actually i think uh viz vision's wife in
that comic gives him
lets him eat some like a type of floral
thing
and that the dog eats it and he got it
from the yard of agatha harkness
um but it's like a type of plant that
lets you see the future by crying oh
azaleas got it azaleas yeah
right you just created you'll see
the day you die some people are saying
that sparky might have killed himself
that like the moment wiccan or i guess
we'll say
billy kaplan touched the food to his
temple and said speak
that was uh him awakening the way vision
can awaken
people by touching their temples and
that awoke the dog
to be like i need to be free from this
hell
and then the dog made it suicide which
would be
horrible i don't think that happened oh
my the dog says
i gotta get out of here and starts
eating azaleas till he dies that'd be
awful that'd be horrific so what do you
think happened jessica do you think
agnes killed this dog
i told you it was wanda but you got you
got defensive so no you i didn't get you
so yes you did i think i think it's
wanda because
not anything like i mean she killed a
dog so i can't be like not
too bad but like i think it was the
learning situation of just like it's
like as soon as the mailman walked by he
said your mom will find him like don't
worry or like
he won't get far with your mom and it's
just like why wouldn't he get far
because of my mom and i think she
intentionally like
made him stop a living and then that's
when we're getting the story of like
that's why i also think it's like she's
still doing this stuff deep deep down
because it could be her being like oh i
have to piece together
death for my kids but also internally
i'm arguing with myself about
how i resurrected my husband i think
wanda is
only in control of so much like i think
what we're saying the reason she can't
control vision the reason bad things
happen is that she doesn't have total
control over this reality
and that might just be she bit off more
than she could chew uh
trying to hold on to a thousand people
even if she was able to almost kill
thanos
uh i think that's a hard thing to do to
create like a fake reality and maintain
it so everyone stays plugged in and
happy and nothing bad happens
i think it's a hard thing to control and
i also think people are working against
her here
and that's why i think agnes did it i i
think that's
i mean that that was my read the moment
i saw her be like she was
it looked like she was trying to bury
that dog yeah she was trying to hide it
a little bit
she was being very she's being hella sus
if this was among us like she would be
the imposter for sure i think this is a
classic
uh and your little dog too like this is
a
dog who is barking at the right person
and that witch is like
screw this dog i want this dog dead oh
yeah what if sparky was noticing
something else and that's when
she was like
and just like oh i wrapped him in a
blankie right
i think i think sparky might have
spotted ralph and then uh
and then they she knows that that kid
wiccan uh
it was teaching him to speak and was
worried that this dog was gonna start
talking and spilling the beans
okay so yeah that could absolutely be
the case that the dog noticed
something and then maybe that would mean
like the reaction to like you can bring
people back was more out of fear because
she was like
oh i killed this dog and don't want you
to know why i killed this dog
and that's why she was like oh [ __ ]
please don't bring this thing back to
the watch
she's like i gotta hide the body and she
just runs off and goes to a
first ralph's calling me no he's not
trying to run with the dog in her
blanket
wtf is wanda's history with hayward
because it's obviously
uncomfortable it's very uncomfortable
yeah okay so let's uh so we got some
confirmation that
wanda did steal vision's corpse and it
looked like in that sword facility they
had him in pieces
it looks like hayward's mission of
nanotech of robotics that was
true they they were pulling that all
from visions corpse for weaponization
purposes
mm-hmm 100
we were right on that we were right on
that we knew that's the sentient weapon
they were making
and that's that's why i'm so upset
that's why i'm so upset
when they were talking about his will
they were like that goes that goes
against his will he didn't want to be a
weapon i was like he's not a weapon in
there but he was about to be a weapon
out here
yeah you were totally gonna turn him
into a gun that someone at sword was
just gonna pick up a
firing willy nilly absolutely we're
gonna like use him as a weapon
like so they're going against his will
and that's why wanda stole that corpse
not only because she's in love with him
but
because she's in love with him but also
because it's like they were gonna
weaponize him
yeah i agree and i think wanda not only
knew that she and hayward must have
talked before right because that
standoff outside wesley she called him
director hayward she knew who he was
so they must have talked at some point
which again i think he knows something
about what she's trying to do
he knew what he was sending monica to i
don't know why she's just not
i understand that she's in like the heat
of the moment but i just don't
understand why she's just not being up
front
if i came out of that bubble i would
have been like why would you give me the
directions of vision and then
turn on me like who are you like i would
make it clear to everyone standing
outside that like
he did he has something to do with it
unless unless
who we saw outside westview was not
actually wanda
stop it throw in that drone
i'm not gonna go also we had so many
theories of like this
is mephisto's outline coming out of this
bubble and i was like watch it be wanda
and it is
as of this week when i we finally got a
clear shot of that yeah
we got a clear shot by then i was able
to call a spade a spade
and a wanda awana it is like oh weird
though
because this this scene was fascinating
to see elizabeth olsen
channel this kind of dark side of her
because uh it tells us that
she is a more active threat like she
does want she hates sword and i think
that tells us that she really just hates
hayward and sword for doing to vision
what they were doing
i don't know if it means she hates
everyone in the world because as monica
said you did bring me in to help deliver
her babies
so i think she's able to discern between
um friendly and faux but i
think uh she did construct this as a
home for herself
uh and she might be under a different
kind of spell or she might have made her
own kind of deal with the devil to do it
but just not realizing what deal she
made stop it
i'm gonna even after it's not revealed
to me mephisto i'm still gonna say
uh mephisto won the election oh
no i will be okay with that one though
yeah i could see that
i think i honestly will probably end up
going with that theory of just yeah
she's upset with swords she
walked in on them dissecting his body
but again
i have to ask how did she know where to
go how did she know where the body was
how did she figure
all this stuff out because it seems like
she's doing this all on her own
seemingly which
outside the bubble when she found his
body she wasn't someone had to tell her
where it was
yeah and it's not like uh it was just in
the aftermath of the battle of
avengers end game it had been recovered
years earlier from wakanda which is
fascinating right
why would wakanda be okay with giving up
this corpse
because it's made of vibranium don't you
think they would want to be like no this
is our substance we'll melt him down and
turn him into a couple badass spears
that's probably what sword was doing
sword was like we own him so
yeah he's government property he's us
government property yeah
i mean that is a fascinating question
jessica i want to know what wanda's war
path was
she's kind of like the bride and kill
bill what was her list to get to this
point you know
oh yeah and also why i think that i
think that's true i think the government
was like this is our body
we own it um now that like tony's i
don't know they're like now that nothing
that
he that invented this thing is still
alive like we own him
because i was like i bet wakanda tried
wakanda was like we can keep him here
and wanda is probably cool with that
because she got to be with him but wanda
doesn't get to be with his dead body
while they dissect it um
so what was monica's awkward reaction to
hearing captain marvel's name
okay lots of theories on this one yeah
actually we have a couple questions
let's shout out the questions who asked
it
why does monica just blow off jimmy
woo's
mention of captain marvel that's what my
biggest question is what's up with the
beef between monica
and captain marvel okay so you guys read
it as a beef
it is a beef she was like not a fan do
you think maybe she blames
um carol danvers for what happened to
her mom maria rambo absolutely well
i i think it's two things i think there
could be two things and i'll tell you
one i'll tell you both actually
so there's a possibility that a um
she only comes to see nick fury she
doesn't come to see her best friend
like and as a daughter watching that and
maybe seeing her mom be like i wish she
would come visit me
it's probably like spiteful and then her
mom's dying of cancer and it's like is
she coming to visit
also we don't know what was happening in
between that time what if
she got cancer doing something with
carol danvers
what if they were like traveling or
doing something and she
was there like she didn't affect captain
marvel obviously like it would affect a
normal human being
and so i think it's spite out of just
like she wasn't there for my mom
she was never there for my mom and she
didn't save my mom she could have saved
my mom
and she could have saved my mom and she
didn't and so i think and also it's like
yeah she's been in that hospital room
with her mom the entire time and she's
probably like
where the like where the hell is captain
marvel where is carol
so i think it's out of just like no i
don't want to talk about her
all right let's talk about this
aerospace engineer was uh monica
mentioned
i know an aerospace engineer and we
never saw who that was was it just that
other drone pilot no i think you're
right jessica i think this was reed
richards
i think uh this is a setup for for the
fantastic
i think it's getting ready also wasn't
the fantastic four like
in space at one point like that's how
they're found is this gonna be
is that fantastic they go to space
they're on a space mission
they uh get uh trapped in the negative
zone for a period of time
and then they escape and then now they
have powers of stretchiness and
invisibility etc are fantastic four
could be the origin they could be the
sword agents that got lost in space
it would be cool i'll say that uh you
know now think of it an aerospace
engineer
uh reed richards is so much more than an
aerospace engineer
yeah he's everything yes he is a
scientist but the guy
came up with like you know
interdimensional travel and stuff like
that uh he's not just a dude working for
boeing
like he's an astronaut no offense to
people working for boeing
in seattle washington this is not a
seattle slander page
seattle working for boeing just i think
aerospace engineers are cool they they
make cool stuff
you're working at spacex good thank you
for keeping us focused on the stars
and technology you're freaking mr
fantastic
what if it's like doctor doom
was it just like a friend's like hey i'm
gonna hook you up with this drone
and um this show has too much of monica
rambo just piloting drones
well hayward's like stop stop doing
stuff he does not want her touching too
many things
uh so that's why they give her these
drums um and possibly
doctor doom i guess it could be like
there's so many engineers in marvel i
was like it could be
like hank pym but i don't know where he
would he
he's probably busy during this well like
the the context of it was
she's like i know a great aerospace
engineer who can help us yeah and the
next stage she has a specifically
80s drone which that was one bit of
logic that kind of confused me this
episode like
i assumed we did have drones in the 80s
but like why would she think that monica
would just look at that and be like oh
a military drone flying through a
neighborhood oh well it's the 80s
version of it so that's okay
no of course she's gonna see it it
wasn't an 80s drone
i think it was like a drone from the 80s
i don't think they built it to look like
an 80s drone because that's why they
came out okay
yeah yeah but like even still it's a
dumb plan to think like
oh yeah if you're in a very neighborhood
if a military drone is flying through
your neighborhood it's loud as hell
like of course you can see it as a
threat like why would she think that
would just be like oh yeah no it fits
with the time period so it's okay
i thought she was going to come up with
like a delorean or something
side notes i know just because you said
delorean i don't know why this made me
think of it
so if monica got her and like the older
older comics when she got her powers
from basically like
beating a weapon and getting its powers
when it exploded
what if that scene where she's driving
she's obviously driving that tank
because she talked about
how they need to make some sort of
vehicle that can like do folk
have like reverse photons and yeah
so she's driving that in what if when
those two things crash because they
built this thing with
like weapon like i think that i think
it's the shot that has the chemicals on
the van maybe not
but like they've made this machine to
counteract wanda
but what if her inside the machine just
gets the powers that it's combining
wandas and the truck and that's how
we're gonna get photon that'd be dope
i would love to see uh that kind of
origin story
uh i just wanted to be clear and
decisive i don't
i'm kind of done with like accidental
power uh acquisition
true um it kind of it's not fun like it
wasn't fun when carol danvers just got
barfed radiation on her i
i just think it's better in stories and
this is a problem in a lot of comics
right it's not just the mcu
i i want it to be like an active choice
that you make that leads to you getting
powers well that's
the act of choice is by the villains oh
yeah you think they chose their powers
and then the hero was beat throwed upon
them powers
yeah i just want it to be some kind of
like extension of their character at
least you know it can be accidental but
i want it to be like justified where
it's like of course this person would
get this kind of powers because they're
always doing stuff like this well yeah
every villain doc ock
everybody but i get i get where you're
coming from but it wouldn't follow the
hero's journey
and also one of their parents have to be
dead so that's true
she doesn't have a dead parent she's a
she needs a mentor hey guys
ding ding monica has a dead parent
that's heartbreak so yeah let us know
who you think this engineer was i think
it might be a little too
cute for it just to be reed richards um
i think that there's gonna be rather
than just like oh remember that
off-screen
aerospace engineer they mentioned in
episode five of one division what if
that was mr fantastic
no i don't think it's gonna be that i
think it was just like weird writing
honestly in that moment there's just so
much weird about what happened they're
gonna reveal it and they're gonna reveal
it and it's gonna be john krasinski and
your cameo that's supposed to be really
big i'm gonna be like okay it's john
krasinski
i won't complain if that's the case we
gotta check in with what the devil
um but do you think there's anything to
this uh i just want you to come at me
jessica do you think i'm barking up the
wrong
sparky tree by saying evan peters could
be uh
mephisto i think we both agreed on that
at the very beginning
like when we first like previewed this
and for the first two episodes
or even a little bit like rogue theories
we were like oh evan peters rumored to
be in it he's my festo like he has to be
to torture wanda
i get where it's coming from but now
that for my own being i'm like
there's so much happening there's so
much happening there is
way more than i thought so if memphis is
in that world that means like
wanda is kind of a villain too and then
that means hayward's also kind of a
villain
i just think a lot of han a lot of hands
in the pot
a lot a lot of a lot of beets in the
soup and
that i made that up
i love it a lot of beets in the soup and
i just feel like
i don't know i feel like they wouldn't
have mentioned that like you can be
brought back to life in that world like
and come out
living and it'd still be mafesto but i
get where you're coming from it was my
theory at the jump 2.
it's just unraveling it's like a fruit
roll-up i'm like
i'm seeing too much for it to be true
anymore yeah that is me that is me i
completely
understand everyone else's argument that
it could it's gonna feel weird
unless they do some other uh like here's
what we do know we know agnes is
a witch um and i think if we can just
explore more of that character
development of agnes
as agatha harkness methisto's kind of a
package deal
with agatha heart yes um because as the
witch she worships satan
uh and i think the if if it's just
something like
we see her in a seance at some point in
a scene
even we don't hear she's talking to if
she's praying to someone
that's someone's mephisto uh now will
that mephisto be the one behind all this
we'll see
i mean at this point uh uh it's been
kind of a joke that i've been having to
double down on
this stuff i don't mind doing it i'm
jumping ship and you're like well we're
still
on this i'll make this promise i'll
promise to you jessica i'll promise all
of our viewers i will not
pretend like i never said it was gonna
be mephisto i will own up to it
uh you guys have been on this journey
with me you know what clues i've been
seeing
uh and it's more than the clues it's
just the logic of why would you put agg
of the hardness in something if not
you know tie in that side of the of the
marvel world
uh i think if it doesn't happen here
it's gonna happen eventually it should
happen and these arguments
that say disney plus would never feature
mephisto hey i've made that same
argument before
bucko this episode it's so dark dude
it's so much harcous
hocus pocus has hocus pocus pg movie on
disney plus
disney plus is not in china by the time
it rolls out in china we're gonna have
eight other marvel uh disney plus shows
that chinese audiences will be able to
devour they're not gonna care too much
about wanda vision anywhere
anyway they'll just be like maybe
archive continent uh content
that the sensors allow through or not
and it's not to matter
because we're going to have things like
multiverse of madness that define what
the multiverse is they're going to
need monovision so i think it's totally
possible that you can have content on
disney plus that is dark that deals with
satan there are episodes of the simpsons
that have satan appear in it that you
can watch on disney plus uh
i know that argument i know how the
chinese film board works you don't have
to lecture me on
on twitter because you can watch some
video i made eight months ago where i
lectured you on it
thank you yeah haven't you guys seen
that so raven
haven't you seen that yeah
[Laughter]
don't see what you just did well that is
it for this episode of the inside marvel
our wanna vision after show
of episode five we will be back next
week to break down the biggest wtfs of
episode
six um and we're gonna continue the show
actually if you're on stereo right now
stick around because we are now going to
take your questions
but if you missed that be sure to join
us next week live at 8 a.m pacific time
it's a really stereo is kind of like an
after party for the after show
and you can download and follow us on
that free stereo app stereo dot com
new rock starts to be part of the fun uh
and again we are doing three
weekly shows on the stereo app
stereo.com new rockstars
to join that conversation jess thanks
for joining me every week it gets more
and more fun
i love going nerdy with you i love you
calling me out on my [ __ ]
uh it's this is the best way you need
that you need that sometimes
i do i do not not you specifically
people everyone needs someone that calls
them out uh you can follow jessica
at lulu underscore clemens on twitter
just lulu clemens on other platforms you
can follow me at ea boss follow new
rockstars subscribe to inside marvel
wherever you get your podcast
and uh we're going to close with our
favorite moment of the episode
[Music]
you